we've got a massive story we did a we
had a great weekend but we got a massive
story that we got to talk about um
a [ __ ] boy is getting canceled right now
i know dude i know [ __ ] boy's getting
cancer right now and i think we got to
come to his defense of course we do
we gotta come to his defense because
west elm caleb if you guys don't know
who west helm caleb is legend let's go
through the story of west elm caitlyn do
you who do you think is most versed on
this story right now mark do you have a
good i got something okay
break it down break down the story of
west elm get the facts only yeah only
the facts yeah just the facts
we care about facts over here okay facts
no feelings i'm gonna do my best with
this i try to do the digimon pokemon
story and i got cooked for it i had i
had judea
hey
yeah i had him hit me up he's like y'all
got that [ __ ] completely wrong that's so
funny mark like a true white man forgot
a whole n word that was said that
started the whole conversation it's
disputed
it's disputed
montana could do it she could do it oh
that's a good thing
what is she what's her background
moroccan moroccan
i think that they should be able to say
at the least why is that
because arabs still got slaves bro
white people we tapped out we were like
nah that's just [ __ ] up but you go to
parts of the world them arabs still got
black slaves bro they can't be dropping
that [ __ ]
huh
okay how are you feeling now i'm team
digimon
okay little pokey man walking around
here
i didn't know that she was uh
i mean could dove say it there's no way
no come on the guy wears too much
cashmere yeah
there's a certain amount of cashmere you
could wear where it just stops you from
saying the end yeah completely what what
amount is it out one percent one yeah
why don't you [ __ ]
episode with the one dot on it i've
never seen it the best episode i've
never seen it
[ __ ]
yeah
okay
so so uh
so basically break this this story west
dumb kid was being called new york's uh
most eligible [ __ ] boy
move over pete davidson
west help caleb so basically there's a
woman that posted a tick tock and said
oh we lost our son god damn it woman
that posted take doctor said uh
basically just like a joke like omg
caleb if you see this like i hate you
and it's like her getting ghosted and
she's like dating in new york is so hard
and then all these people in the
comments are like omg like caleb from
west elm and she's like people are like
caleb from west coast okay boy all these
comments okay
see you out here building more than
furniture i'm sad so now all these other
girls are making tick tocks like yo i
dated this guy west elm caleb he said he
was 6'4 uh we met on hinge he said that
he was a furniture designer at uh west
elm yep this is a picture of what he
looks like
yeah we talked we like went back and
forth you hate him bro he quote unquote
you hate him
could be good-looking
no the dudes could be good looking
that's a little cute
you take a few inches off your hair put
it on his body that's literally be you
can finish his beard honestly
they sent me a couch with no [ __ ]
feet on it no yes [ __ ] west you guys
busy
[ __ ]
took me off my feet
i hate them but yeah so basically he's
all over hinge and now there's like over
25 30 women that said i went on a date
with west home caleb and they all have
the same story they're like yeah we met
on the check exact same messages copy
pasted it send me messages he sent me
the same spotify playlist like hey girl
like i love you i sent this for you blah
blah blah okay i don't know which ones
like met up with him and went on dates
with him or not uh-huh he sent one girl
dick pics twice he must have liked her
yeah
what's he packing bro
he didn't say she didn't post that no no
no that's how you know you're getting a
[ __ ] guy
we've all been seeing it but if
this if my girl sits in my west elm
couch i'm like yo sit the [ __ ] up yeah
right no stand up damn bro okay keep
going uh but yeah basically he would
like talk to girls and then just ghost
them and now all these girls are now
mobbing him saying like yo [ __ ] this guy
he's the biggest [ __ ] boy we hate west
home caleb and now it's gotten even
bigger than that like all these brands
are hopping on it like hellman's mayo
said like yo west elm caleb like doesn't
[ __ ] with mayo like [ __ ] like that like
people are just like now brands are
jumping on it and now it's just become a
meme tick-tock tweeted about it is how
big it got yeah they went onto twitter
and tweeted about west elmore their own
social media app yeah they went on a
different way to spread the word yeah
yeah interesting okay so now it's just
become a massive thing and the first
conversation that comes up is like is
this love bombing is he being
manipulative
you can't this was was so great you
can't even be nice to women
you nice to a woman it's love bombing i
looked into this it's apparently the
precursor to the bombing is that [ __ ]
that obama would do okay i don't know
weddings
that's not what it is what is that oh
drone strikes that's a good that's a
drone strike
you know who can use the new furniture
okay go so basically is like is what he
did [ __ ] up the other thing that i
will say that is important note is that
apparently he told some woman that he
was exclusive with them
so he was like talking all these
different women dating a bunch of them
at the same time and telling specific
ones like yo it's just you and me like i
love you and we know that for a fact but
that's what she said
[Laughter]
caleb [ __ ] up is he a [ __ ] boy okay uh
is he a [ __ ] way
yeah he's a [ __ ] boy i want to point out
this uh the ghosting [ __ ] we're all done
it before i do think it's it's whack
uh but we've all done it hundred percent
part of growing up exactly it is 25 the
only reason we do is because we're all
[ __ ] yeah right it's like we're just
scared to like hurt somebody so if we
just ignore it then we and that's
exactly what i said about the girls who
ghosted me they just need to grow up
she just needs to grow up yeah bruh son
hey if it's a type of rejection i'll
probably bend that [ __ ]
probably i don't know specifics
block them shits out
yes yes save from your chances
you really only dated
not for real are they just ghosting you
up and [ __ ] no i don't know if i got
ghosted i definitely got rejected for
sure in many different ways i probably
got ghosted yeah it happened
if you ain't been ghosted you ain't [ __ ]
you ain't put yourself out there oh
you've never been ghosted of course i
have everybody been ghosted yeah i'll be
honest i just said that i might not have
been ghosted hey i mean i promise
you i'm too forgetful super forgiving
what can i do
you know what i mean i got to fall in
love it is what it is we all have other
plans sometimes y'all never had other
plans god's will
to be fair you ended up costing her
quite a bit of money
no that's on her quite a bit quite like
eight figures but i made the other
caller daddy yeah a good amount you
should speak against you cost him a lot
of money with bitcoin bro you're talking
about it hey cost me all this goddamn
money i've been doing that sometimes i
ghosted texting you to sell it
i forgot you ever heard eric myers joke
about ghosting no what do you say he's
like they should not call it ghosting
because ghosting is like when something
comes to your house and [ __ ] you all
the time like they should call it they
should call it sasquatching like you see
them for a little bit and they just
[ __ ] run into the woods yeah that's
actually great because a ghost is going
to terrorize you yeah
it's there all the time yeah
because ghosts don't disappear yeah they
are there around they're always there
haunting you forever that's what happens
when we leave it up to women to make up
the terms
right
yeah you gotta watch some paranormal
activities
okay so so this guy is it wrong what he
did what i think is really funny
it's actually really funny based on uh
just based on like the the heels of our
conversation last week when we were
talking about like what is the proper
way to get women et cetera like here's
an example of a guy who's not a [ __ ]
crypto billionaire he's not an athlete
he's not a rapper the guy designs
furniture for west elm probably does
okay but not crazy okay lives in
brooklyn he's not living in some
high-rise [ __ ] manhattan apartment
you know there's something beautiful in
soho with a mezzanine or roof access
really just wonderful
what what
you know i mean marry me talk about you
i'm what are you i'm a married man yeah
i'm a very man dude i'm a married man
yeah he happens to live in soho some of
us live in high rises couple floors
underneath derrick grows it is what it
is
it is what it is you could move up and
live above him yeah
basketball essentially it's actually
impossible to live above where he lives
what are we even talking about even
right
you know just because it says pentax
doesn't mean there aren't higher
penthouses that's true that's a good ass
it might be a higher pent-up that's a
good answer but enough about us yeah i'm
not talking about us we're not talking
about us oh yeah you're right any
hypothetical enough about those uh
incredibly successful people um the
point is this guy
is not what we think the ideal man he is
six four yeah if you six four that's
[ __ ] that's helpful allegedly six
four allegedly six fours
[Music]
let's go back to back let's go back to
back me and what's up caleb
you five hours
okay so
this is important
this guy
was not being mean to these girls upon
meeting them he was doing the exact
opposite thing that we're told by like
the pickup artist and [ __ ] right he's
love bombing yeah you're so amazing i
made a playlist for you it literally is
terrifying what he's doing is a symphony
so he simply this guy simped himself
according to the rules this guy sent
himself into having sex with half in new
york city that's crazy
is it possible that so many people are
following the pickup artist techniques
that now the unique way to hit on a
woman
is to go from symptom
that's simple to pimp it when you really
think about it be nice to these girls
it's going to be such a
shocking experience for them
they're going to be oh my god maybe this
guy i really like him now what i will
say is quite interesting is these girls
got on top of it and became a tick-tock
friend
what i think is kind of funny is if he
was one of these millionaires if he was
a finance douche if he was drake if he
was uh odell beckham jr these girls
would be fine with being ghosted they
understand it they understand that their
ego could tolerate it and what's funny
about this and this is the insulting
thing is they're not upset they got
ghosted they're upset that they got
ghosted by a guy that they thought they
were better than
[ __ ] that's the ego thing is going to
say i got ghosted by the guy who makes
furniture for west now yeah the [ __ ] you
do you're not a drake you're not how
dare you have sex with all of us and not
be famous or successful enough
restoration hardware maybe
i need some real nice bougie [ __ ] right
isn't that interesting like
it's an ego check it i don't even know
if the girls that are coming out saying
it realize it let me push back on that
point even though i don't i think a lot
of these girls are overreacting crazy
but
a celeb wouldn't necessarily show a
bunch of affection up top and be like i
love you marry me go make a playlist you
don't have to i don't disagree with your
general point but that's one thing that
i'm i'm not sure i agree with they're
reacting to the love bomb they're
reacting to the love bomb now i i don't
want to seem rude here oh go finish yeah
here's the thing i call i looked into
this love-bombing thing yes they call it
a precursor to abuse so then women are
calling it abuse
now if a guy does that and then abuses
you that's a [ __ ] criminal if a guy
does that and doesn't abuse you that's
not abuse a precursor is not the same
every fight the precursor is an argument
every fistfight the precursor is an
argument the argument's not a crime you
can call it it's an argument yeah that's
all that [ __ ] is i'm being nice
i can't be nice i don't know if it's any
more manipulative than like uh looking
completely different in your instagram
pictures than you do in real life
is it emotional
versus physical catfishing
are we all i think uh what is it the
great chris rock joke you didn't meet me
you met my representative
right this is back in the day before
photoshop and all these other things but
like yeah everybody's on their best
behavior at the beginning of a date yeah
my apartment's clean just in case yeah
right my apartment ain't always clean
yeah right everything's clean i'm
shaving up downstairs i took a shower
i might get a middle hammer toe sucked
if my feet are washed bro and if it's
not she's not going to do that you call
it a hammer
little hammer bro
i got the middle hand she says bring out
the hammer what do you do is put your
legs
hey listen to this hammer everything's a
nail is that the same what is this thing
what does that say how is it right there
yeah you got a hammer every problem
yeah
you know what time it is [ __ ] it still
don't make sense
okay but i guess what i'm trying to say
is is that like to act like neither
party is representing themselves
uh completely authentically or an act
like both parties are representing
themselves completely authentically upon
meeting yeah i think is unfair it's
completely unfair and straying from that
is somehow abusive no yeah i hate this
just throwing the [ __ ] word a bit
we're throwing that out like i need to
see some real abuse honestly like abuse
and like goat we just throw out
yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying like a
[ __ ] shoots a paper towel into a
trash can
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying like every
there's 50 goats goat is greatest of all
time yeah there's just one yeah right so
i agree i think there was just overusing
that [ __ ] but but with this specific
thing
damn i [ __ ] that word uh
with this specific thing with west elm
caleb i what i find it interesting is
like it's very hard to
it's very hard for people to just go i
guess he didn't like
you know what i'm saying like if he's
either a fuckboy manipulative [ __ ]
and i maybe he did that to a few people
and that's [ __ ] up but some of y'all
yeah yeah but you know what's crazy
is the ones he said we're exclusive
[ __ ] up [ __ ] but one of the girls who
went on tick-tock to talk about that she
was like oh i was swiping i met this guy
i'm gonna go on a date and add him to my
arsenal
so she's saying i'm about to ask
all the other dudes i'm talking to you
already and now you're mad that he's
dating you [ __ ] girl here [ __ ] boy you
got [ __ ] yeah you aren't good enough for
him and that's where your ego for sure
is it is it like unethical to go on the
same date or to do the same kind of
behaviors with the same girl is it
unethical with different girls for that
girl to wear the same skirt
with the same lingerie with the same
sexy ass bra
playlist where he's like i made this for
you that's the emotional equivalent for
us
do what i mean like make me the same
bacon egg and cheese you made a bunch of
other [ __ ] in the morning is
that unethical let's stop acting like
we're not repeating tactics that we know
that can be successful yeah right if
those things are kind and nice what's
the problem
giving someone a playlist of music that
you think they might enjoy yeah you're
doing it so you guys may build that
connection but i don't think that that's
the worst thing a guy's ever done it's
not the worst it's a little slightly to
be like i made this for you but okay hey
i'm slightly [ __ ] up this guy's going
viral for this oh gosh is it wrong to
take a girl to the same restaurant that
you took another girl too no no
like can you never repeat anything yes
yeah
and he could just be repeating these
same tactics that he's had great dates
on until he finds the one exactly
yeah and none of y'all were there
that's it like and there's nothing wrong
with not being the one you're gonna be
somebody's one is west elm caleb an
[ __ ] or are you just boring
or did you just
did you just lie about how hot you were
yeah
y'all know me i dated a lot i was out
here in the world yeah i met the one
yeah and the one
was the one that i needed to be with
wanted to be with locked in with
okay
y'all just weren't the one
that just weren't the one it is what it
is yeah that happens maybe he didn't
appreciate you look bombing him where
you pretend you're super hot and then he
sees you you're like are you all right
oh wow oh wow i'm a 6'4 better looking
version of mark i'm gonna settle for
this exactly got six four mark better
looking bill furniture i still got a
growth spurt coming watch yeah
i got a little bit okay i will say i
feel bad for him only because i feel
like yeah he's a [ __ ] boy but now he's
just a
like a representation of all the [ __ ]
boys yeah
every piece of [ __ ] guy you've ever met
he's this guy he's getting karen's you
know what i mean yeah
like
where now he's not like people are
forgetting that he's like a person and
they're just jumping on because he's the
representative of a fight they're trying
to get him fired from his job
they're tagging west elm in it like west
elm is supposed to be like all right man
during your time off you should have
been digging down all these girls in new
york city i think we need to get rid of
you you're a danger and we're probably
gonna fire this guy that'd be [ __ ] up
because it's just like we don't need
this caleb if you get fired we'll let
you build all the furniture for our new
stuff hey hey
i mean necessarily
i mean that sincerely i want to hire you
we want him on the podcast i tried i was
dm and girls that he dated
i was married andrew is married in girls
dm's like yo free caleb
i bet you're going to do this playlist
yeah i bet you just get some more
because girls got to find out all these
girls like oh [ __ ] i want to see what's
so special
and none of them hated on the dick none
of them hated on like so far as of what
i've seen like none of them hated on the
experience they enjoyed being with him
yeah and they had a good time with him
from what i see so they're upset that he
didn't share that yeah which is always
an ego hit that [ __ ] sucks
it hits you you're like god damn it son
of a [ __ ] right this person didn't like
me as much as i like them yeah that's
frustrating to take that to the internet
and try to trash somebody and like
galvanize and get a bunch of other
people together regardless guys or girls
doing that to the opposite sex it's just
[ __ ] up
that's [ __ ] up you know what's funny
he there's a text of him responding to
one of the girls and he's like yo my
life has been ruined a lot of girls are
just making stuff up that isn't true
some of these girls are saying i didn't
pay for dates and it's like that's the
thing yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but how could he afford all these dates
that's a lot of dates westone's paying
them good friends we'll talk like i
remember back in the day when i was
dating a lot and i was like i think i
got to start choosing yeah it was crazy
like restaurants yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like what are we doing exactly
yeah like jewelry advertisers are like
yo yeah
grabbed some food before yeah that's why
i remember my pickup line used to be on
the apps the first one was do you like
tacos nacho nachos yeah i remember i
tried that i got ghosted
that should work every time
the girl was spanish and i i realized
that's a little bit insensitive
you know
imagine an indian girl you like 10 30
chicken
[ __ ] up i should have looked into that
app that was on me fine so that line
might work that [ __ ] worked that was
years ago it probably doesn't work now
but that [ __ ] used to work yeah you said
it to me and i was like oh [ __ ] this guy
figure something out
everybody likes nachos they do not
everyone that's not everyone this is
lactose intolerant [ __ ] not
everybody's a vegan at all yeah that was
extra [ __ ] but back there
yeah
absolute banger free west elm caleb
that's all i gotta say
give this guy's life back stop [ __ ]
piling and we're offering you the forum
west down yeah we need west elmo or we
want one of the girls that he dated
maybe one of the girls he dated and west
elm together oh
that would be fine yeah let's see if he
is six four
yeah measure that's why we're bringing
them in right yeah that's why okay yeah
this is gonna be good